In the last lesson, we saw that some things can grow and decay exponentially.
We explored things like this with functions of the form y equals a to the x and
y equals a to the negative x. But, exponential functions can also be multiplied
by constants, just like we saw with different forms of interest. For a
continuously compounded interest for example, we looked at the equation a A
equals P times e to the rt. Where P is the amount of money invested, the
principal, r is the rate of interest per year written as a decimal, and t is
the time in years that the money's been invested for. Another example of a
function that fits this form is the way that bacteria die off when a drug is
administered. In this case, P represents the initial amount of what we're
starting with, which this time is the number of bacteria, r this time is the
decay rate of how quickly the bacteria die off, and t here is the time period
we're considering measured in hours. So for example, if the starting number of
bacteria is 1,000 and the rate at which they decay or die off is negative 0.5.
What is the function B of t for the number of bacteria alive after t hours?
Please write it in here.